I'm Tim Jakes and I am Scoutmaster with Troop 93 in Westchester, Pennsylvania.
This edition of Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
Hey, everybody, this is Clark Green. It's summertime and so our next few podcasts feature on-court presentations
from our archives, And this week I'll be playing an interview that I conducted several years ago
with David Scott, who is the author of a fantastic scouting history book called The Scouting Party.
As always, this podcast is only possible because of the generosity of the folks who become ScoutmasterCGcom backers.
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find out how you can become a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
We'll be back with our regular schedule of podcasts in a few weeks. Until then, let's get started, shall we?
Today I am speaking with historian, author and scouter, David C Scott, who has a new book that will be available
at the end of this month, June of 2010,, called The Scouting Party, subtitled:
Pioneering and Preservation: Progressivism and Preparedness in the Making of the Boy Scouts of America.
Good afternoon, David. How are you?
I'm, Mark, doing great.
You were kind enough to send me a review copy and I devoured it, and it is a really interesting and thorough take
on the. it's about the first ten years of the Scouting Movement, is it not?
I would say that that's a fair assessment. Yes, I took a lot of time to put as much as I could
in the first ten years, the first decade since they were the. that was the most important in terms of
criticality, if you will, the formation of the Boy Scouts of America.
And the party we're talking about in the title of the Scouting Party is Ernest Thompson, Seaton,
Baden Powell and Dan Beard. This is a study of their relationship as three founders of Scouting.
There are different influences and everything, and it wasn't always an easy relationship between these three, was it?
No, there are three massive egos and I'm sure that a couple of them wouldn't have made it out of a room
if they were all three put together in the same room and started their negotiations of how to make it work.
So it was very rare that all three of them were seen together- once in 1910 and once in 1912,
but that was by the extent of it. And, yes, photographs were taken, so we do have documentation
that they were together and they all three survived, but it had to have been quite a meeting of the minds
when they were together.
What I found really fascinating was- and I think anybody who's been around a little bit in Scouting
and has worked in a trooper, a packer, a crew and worked in a district or council level position
understands that it, like you said, it takes some massive egos sometimes to make things go
and they don't always get along, but the product is really what we keep our eyes on.
I was fascinated to learn that Ernest Thompson Seaton seems to be the guy with the original idea.
Well, he was, and when he met with Robert Bated-Pole in October of 1906,
a BP was finishing off the creation of what he would eventually call his Boy Scouts,
but he didn't have all of the framework set down.
And when he did speak with Seaton at that meeting on October 30th,
the pieces were finally put into place and BP was able to finalize his plan
in several pamphlets that he published in 1907.
Actually, he published two of the three-
Boy Scouting is a suggestion- and then he talked about Brown Sea and his plan,
and that's what finally gelled into what we know now as the Boy Scouting movement,
which I consider being born, really philosophically born- on October 30th of 1906,
but in reality officially born of January 15th 1908,
dating to the publication of BP's seminal work,
the first fortnightly issuance of Scouting for Boys.
The interesting thing is that when Bated-Pole sat down to do this,
he had already seen Ernest Thompson Seaton's material
about the Woodcraft Indians.
Well, he had, in fact, when Bated-Pole was-
and I say Bated-Pole because that's the way he pronounced his name,
I know that it's
Oh okay,
Going against the grain, but I have a bad habit of doing that,
But anyway, that being said, BP was vacationing at the house of his publisher
Pearson- I can't recall his first name, Arthur Pearson-
That is this house in Surrey, England, in the summer of 1906,
and this package arrived. this parcel arrived
and it was shipped by Ernest Seaton to BP
because Seaton wanted BP's opinion on how to work with him
in terms of broadcasting his Seaton to Woodcraft Indians.
The book was the Birchbark role of the Woodcraft Indians
and that would be the book which would help provide the final piece for BP
to help create his Boy Scouting Scheme, as you call it.
So that package arrived-
An unexpected package, mind you, but it arrived nonetheless,
and that's when the gelling began
To kind of fill people in about Ernest Thompson Seaton.
tell us just a little bit about his history.
Well, Ernest Seaton was a Scots-born Canadian
and he came to the United States in the late 1890s
to eventually get married. essentially is what it was,
but he was living, he and his wife, the, her maiden name being Gallatin,
her name was Grace Gallatin.
They got married and moved to New York in the late 1890s
and Seaton published a book of his animal stories
called Wild Animals I Have Known,
and in that story was, or in that book was, a story
that was based upon his experience with a wolf
in the New Mexico lands, a desert out there named Lobo,
and the popularity of Lobo's story- The King Wolf of the Karumpaw-
that skyrocketed his fame through this book,
because he'd already recently published the story of Lobo
in Scribner's Magazine, and so people knew about Lobo
Well, they wanted to hear more about these animal stories
and these animals that he'd come across,
and what he did was he created a genre of a type of story
to which gave human-like personalities and characteristics
to the animals, and so these stories were incredibly popular
and in fact he made a contract with his publisher, Scribner's,
that he would take no royalties on the first 2,000 copies
of his book, because they didn't think they would sell.
Well, he knew that it would.
but for every copy above 2,000, he would take a double royalty
in a sense, 20%.
Well, after see, that was done around March or April of 1898,
and by December they'd gone through multiple printings
and he was up about, in today's dollars, about 4 million bucks.
So he was about 200,000 royalties, but about 4 million today.
so he was quite a wealthy guy.
He could do whatever he wanted to at that point
and the scouting thing appealed to him.
His approach to nature study was based a lot on
Native American spirituality that he had picked up in his travels.
Absolutely, He was more concerned with the great spirit
as opposed to classic, traditional Christianity
and he believed that the Native American-
or, as he referred to them, of course, the Red Man,
the Native American- was a superior human being
in terms of their spirituality, because they lived off the land
and they did not desecrate it, they didn't destroy it,
they didn't harm it in so much as they could.
so they lived and used the bounty of mother nature
and they respected her.
That was his model for the way an American boy should grow up,
being more like in the model of Tecumseh than anyone else.
I think that was kind of a minority opinion at the time.
Well, it would have to have been a minority opinion,
most definitely. yes,
Seedon was. he was a bit of a visionary
as compared to his compatriots Powell and Beard.
If you look at Baden-Pole and his work on scouting for boys,
he considered the back woodsman
or the knights of the old Chevalric years,
knights of King Arthur, as his model for the scouts.
Well, Daniel Carter Beard, Uncle Dan, Dan Beard, as we call him,
he looked at as the pioneer, the plainsman,
the buckskin man, as the model for the American boy,
the likes of a Theodore Roosevelt
and the likes of George Washington
and the likes of an Abraham Lincoln.
Those were his ideas of the model that an American boy should follow.
And it's interesting to me that the movement that we have today
comes from these kind of disparate influences
and you can't call one of them right and one of them wrong,
but they all came together to form a scouting movement
that's been pretty durable for the past 100 years.
Well, if you look at the contributions,
you would have to think that Dan Beard's patriotism,
that's infused in the Boy Scouts' movement,
Baden Pole, looking back to his knights,
that was heroics and heroism
That is built in the Boy Scouts.
You look at Seton. you look at his vision of the Great Spirit.
That was just one.
You look at Christianity and Judaism
and you see that multi-religious faiths
are built in the Boy Scouts model.
They're all in there.
There's not one particular model that completely dominates,
Completely dominates.
VP certainly has the bulk of the system,
but it doesn't completely dominate.
You look at the order of the arrow
that goes back to Seton,
And the order of the arrow is a huge program
in the Boy Scouts of America.
You can't say that one completely dominates,
but there are certainly major influences
by those three individuals.
You know a lot of histories of scouting
that I have read over time. take this era
and they kind of encapsulate it in a few paragraphs.
While they will mention some of the conflicts
and controversies amongst these three men,
they kind of downplay it.
What I really enjoy about your work, David,
is you just go straight at it,
You don't downplay it or anything
to kind of celebrate the fact that
they were able to work together.
It was the fact of what they were able to contribute
to each other, whether they liked it or not,
And that's the good thing about it.
The accomplishments speak for themselves.
How long do you think you spent working on this thing.
Well, I tag it to about 10 years,
writing about 8 to 10..
For my lights it was well worth it
for the product.
Well, thank you very much.
I know my wife would like to hear that,
because there were many a night
in the early days of the early 2000s
to which I was staying up until 2,
2.30 and 3 in the morning
with these piles of papers
at the dinner table in my computer
And I'm just typing away and thinking
this is horrible,
This is terrible.
There's nothing going to come out of this
but besides a big pile of trash,
Eventually it turned into something,
so that was a good thing.
There are a couple other major players in here,
and one would be a familiar name
to most scouts who've studied a little bit
about the history of the BSA,
and that's West.
James West was the first executive secretary.
within a year or so
He of course made the title of career
the title of chief scout executive.
Jim West was
an incredibly difficult taskmaster
And if he saw a messy desk
he would take that cane
that he walked around with
and he would sweep that desk clean
and say: go, pick it up, put it in the right spot.
He would have a good time at my house,
He would wear his cane out.
I'm sure he wouldn't be very pleased
if he saw the 2400 square feet of warehouse
that are loaded up with books over where I write.
He comes off as being very business-like
and very motivated,
but also he was kind of a cold fish, wasn't he?
Well, he absolutely was.
His biggest goal was to be successful.
We understand that part.
But in a personal level
he wanted to be beloved by the boys,
as were Dan Beard and Ernest Seaton.
But he did not have those skills.
He was a cold fish
and he did not have much of a personality
other than to make people do exactly what he wanted them to do.
but he could not get along with the boys
to the extent that Beard and Seaton were.
They were the symbols of American scouting
for those years.
Seaton fought five and Beard
for the remaining 25 or so
while he was alive.
But that's why he re-received
a letter of Uncle Dan,
the beloved uncle of Boy Scouts.
Just as with the other three,
without West we don't have scouting as we have it today.
If you didn't have West,
you wouldn't have had the last three points of the scout law-
brave, clean and reverent.
Those were added by West.
Oh, no, kidding,
Absolutely yes.
They took the original nine points,
soon to be 10 points, under BP,
and they added brave, clean and reverent.
That's the direction of Jim West.
Another big influence
and big personality
that weaves its way through your narrative in the book
is Boyce.
Well, William D Boyce,
William Dixon Boyce, was a publisher
in Chicago.
He was in England in December of 1909,
and it is at that point
that the Boy Scouts story began.
That's actually when,
according to the information
I would not be able to dig up,
That was the time period
to which he was escorted
across the street
by the unknown Boy Scout.
Not if it happened,
but it's plausible
and the details are listed in the book.
It's kind of a story that's been around,
a legend of the Boy Scouts of America,
and it's been
kind of controversial
as to whether it actually happened or not.
but your conclusion was,
My conclusion is:
I would hate for facts to get in the way of a good story.
but it is in fact plausible.
It is plausible
based upon the dates
and the one day of fog that existed in his area
in 1909 in December,
which would have given him
just enough time to
go to London,
go to the Scout office
and take off for Southampton
on the steamer, going back to the United States
the next day.
It's not that to rest, doesn't it?
I was skeptical as well.
There's not enough facts
to say it didn't happen,
and if you can't prove it didn't happen,
you can't deny that it did
to a certain extent.
It's just one of those things
that you have to look at as saying
it's possible.
These three- Beard and Powell and Seaton-
make conflicting claims
as to who
started what and when.
What's the real
conclusion that you find
about some of these conflicting
claims and things like that?
If you look at the timeline,
Seaton would have based his
Woodcraft Indians organization from 1902
and it was based upon Indian lore.
Now you have Dan Beard
dating his organization.
the original sons of Daniel Boone
and the boy pioneers
date back to 1905.
Then you work on to
what he should directly date his organization.
You can pick two dates.
You can pick Brownsea in July
and August of 2007,
or the actual publication that I do
of Scouting for Boys in January of 1908,
and then the BSA, of course,
1910, February.
There's several things
that you can look at
Seaton as being the originator of,
but BP changed the names
and called it something else.
His organization actually
lasted longer
and was more powerful
and more interesting to other people.
Therefore he gets all the credit
In the contest of ideas.
a lot of this we would put right
in Seaton's lap as being the originator
of a lot of these ideas.
I would say that he has a legitimate claim
on
the origination of
certain aspects of the program.
Actually, for the rest of Seaton's life
he always claimed that
that wasn't exactly the case.
but that was the
lifelong hatred that he had for BP
and it never really went away,
even in the
latest years of their lives.
but the BP always blew it off,
but they never made it public.
Seaton never came out public and said:
BP, you're a plagiarist. but he did say
in his personal letters saying
the guy plagiarized me and so on.
so I was the originator of the Scouting idea.
I can't believe that other people don't see this.
but he never came out
and called it a problem.
He just sort of sat and stewed
in his own little world.
It seems to me the real message
and the real miracle behind this history
is that
even though
these guys had their back and forth
and their problems,
they were all champions of
a single set of ideas
that really has become what we enjoy today.
Well, it was for the boys,
and that you couldn't have a strong military
and you couldn't have a strong
citizenry
if you didn't have strong character.
The growth of the youth movement
and youth education
and patriots and good citizens
was long underway
when BP was
creating his Scouting movement,
because that's exactly what
Seaton and Beard were setting off to do
earlier in that decade.
This is the way that you conclude the book,
if you allow me to read it.
100 years after the BSA's founding,
it's not too late
and maybe an opportune moment
to reconsider
and reintegrate some of the unconventional
and idiosyncratic values
that Seaton and Beard, for that manner,
brought to the Scouting party,
making it irresistible to American boys
and to the nation as a whole.
Revisiting its origins in this way
could very well provide
the Boy Scouts of America with a key to its future.
It's a very modest
conclusion to this, David,
and I'm wondering if you'd like to expand on it for us.
Well, I didn't
write the book to be
a dissertation on
how the Boy Scouts of America have succeeded
or failed in recent years
in their program.
That is for the reader to decide
whether the Boy Scouts have been successful or not,
But what we can say is, in order for the Boy Scouts of America
to be successful in the next 100 years,
they have to appeal
to the boys that live today.
And I've met
a number of boys
who would just forego advancements
for simply being out in the woods.
and that old adage goes
that Scouting is three quarters outing,
and that's exactly what it is.
A lot of boys just don't care to advance,
They just want to get out and be boys.
You know what? that's the same as it was back in 1910.
Back in 1902.
Back in 1905.
That's what boys want to do.
They want to be out, They want to be free,
They want to be running around,
They want to have some focus
on what to accomplish,
whether that's through games or whatever,
But they want to have fun.
F-U-N, capital F-U-N.
And they can do that through Scouting.
and the Boy Scouts have to appeal
to those types of boys in order to survive.
And I suggest that going back to the woods
and staying in the woods
and making sure that you have enough scout camps
and activities of scout camps
that are going to help grow
Now it doesn't mean that you're not going to do
keep creating advancements,
like you know, the video games
activity for the Cub Scouts,
because that's part of life today as well.
So you have to
remain focused upon
what boys want to see,
And I think it's good marketing if they do
do something like that, and they have.
So they have to focus as well
on the outdoors and the camping activities
and a number of council districts
to make exactly that.
I think what's really remarkable
is that this,
as you just said,
is just as attractive and exciting
and engaging to boys now
as it was a hundred years ago.
Boys are the same.
They just have new toys.
Every once in a while, I hear somebody my age
talk about how good things used to be
and how things have changed
and things are either easier or harder
or something like that.
The things that appealed to boys
in 1910 about scouting
are the same things that appeal to them today:
Absolutely
Being outside, messing around, having a good time,
and, whether they like it or not,
they're probably going to get some training
in citizenship.
The book is due to be published
at the end of this month
of June of 2010..
It will be released right around
June 30th. It's at the press right now
And
if I want to get a copy of this right now.
what's the best way
for me to pre-order it?
The best way is to go to Amazoncom
and go to the scouting parties book page
and pre-order there.
I'm going to make sure to have a link
to that for everybody on the blog.
David, I really appreciate the book
and I think you've done a great service to us
shining a light on this period of scouting,
And there's many lessons
to be learned. I really encourage people to read it.
Well, thank you, Clark. I really appreciate that.
It's a no-holds-barred
view at
what actually happened.
It's a fascinating story
about these fascinating men who created a fascinating organization.
I really appreciate your time
and talk to us on the Scoutmaster podcast.
Well, thank you for your kind words.
I want to thank you for listening
to this 275th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch:
Go to scoutmastercgcom
and there you can read our blog
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email. You can join the other
mobile scouts who have the Scoutmaster
CG app on their mobile devices
and you can get the app in the Google Play
or iTunes App Store.
You can experience all the wonders
that are Scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Join the 9,500 folks who like
Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus of
1,200 tweeters on Twitter
and pin the poultry tuner's pictures
that we profit publicly, with
1,900 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
Watch as it's Scoutmaster CG on YouTube.
or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive and very quiet
Scoutmaster CG circle on Google Plus.
Now, if you can't face Facebook
or Twitter makes you better. if you've no interest in Pinterest,
if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus,
don't worry about it. that's okay,
Bunky, zoom into the late 90's
and send me an email.
You can get in touch with me, Clark Green,
at Clark at ScoutmasterCGcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
and let me remind you,
please, that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of anybody except for myself.
Nope, they're not official publications
of any scouting organization
like the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by anybody.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why, thank you, sir? Until next time. everyone
Thank you.